let's jump into this first story all
right we got this from timcast.com Biden
Administration says air near derailed
train and controlled chemical burn is
safe amid concerns of water
contamination as soon as I read that
headline I could hear Luke Rutkowski
screaming at the top of his lungs all
the way from Florida ah because uh as
you know they said the air was safe to
breathe on 9 11 which it absolutely was
not and so the reason in my opinion they
would tell you the air is safe debris is
because they want you to go work to
solve that problem hey look I get it you
got a problem if nobody wants to go and
work to put the fire out and stop the
chemical spill then it keeps getting
worse but you're not going to convince
someone to go do it if you tell them the
truth about how toxic the air is the
Ohio Department of Natural Resources
reports the 3500 fish in the area have
died since the derailment photos of a
actually I think I have a photo right
here is this uh do I have the photo okay
here's the radius the radius Wall Street
Silver says the cloud radius of the
chemical burn in Ohio is huge yup we're
in it